hi this is Jenny she's a robotic
emotional support animal yeah she's
designed to help seniors company my name
is Tom Stevens I am CEO and co-founder
of Tomba my mother raised me around
animals he had horses as pets in the
backyard along with ducks chickens geese
and dogs and cats and so I was raised
around animals and animals played a
special role not only in my life but in
my mother's life after my mother was
diagnosed with Alzheimer's by far the
worst day was taking away her dog
my mother was devastated and it broke my
heart to be the one to have to take her
dog away from her that launched me on a
multi-year research and education effort
to solve my mother's problems
specifically I received my master's in
science from Stanford Business School
the biggest thing I took away from the
MSX program we're really the
relationships that are formed with the
other members of our cohort I came to
love and respect the people that had
many years under their career and could
provide me their insights when a senior
is diagnosed with Alzheimer's or another
causal disease for dementia they began
losing things in their lives where a
senior can form a robust emotional
attachment to an object traditionally
human baby dolls or stuffed animals that
senior gets a great deal of relief and
the tech world my roots fairly ignored
this so what we set out to do is build a
better emotional attachment object jenny
is a fully interactive robotic emotional
support animal she's covered with
sensors she can feel how and where she's
being touched and respond in a manner
that's consistent with how a live animal
would respond by caring for the robot
they again have a sense of purpose where
the well-being of the robot becomes a
focal point in their lives the largest
struggles have really been around
fundraising we ran a Kickstarter
campaign the goal for the Kickstarter
was really to build awareness and to
test the market to see what kind of
response we would receive we received
overwhelming response from seniors with
dementia
to parents of children with autism to
doctors and nurses in hospitals and it
was through that that we realized that
that we were going to be able to build a
fairly robust community surrounding our
product my mother passed away in October
of 2018 and she was actually the
inspiration behind the name she just
asked me what are you gonna name the
company I said well I'm not sure she
said well how about Tom that led us to
to call it Tom Bott so every day when
the company's name is used I think back
to my mother and all of the wonderful
work that she did with us to help us get
our products to a place where they were
useful and purposeful for other people
[Music]